tu as lu le houellebecq we come back est
en a pensé et bah écoute c'est non mais
j'allais écouter ou à 19h19 on va faire
comme si on était chez ben haim a échu
doc gynéco alors vas-y tu commentes
ue-chine rébénacq animaux autrement
qu'en voiture chine les ménages voient
alors suivi frise le sans rigoler la
nuit avec son idée si elle est là si
benali mais là ce soir
fa la la on imagine vous attendez les
gars vous êtes encore là c'est une
hypothèse n'a pas coché il est
tranquillement chez lui en train de
manger des salsifis j'ai pas sûr parce
qu'ils bouffent mais pourquoi on sait
pas ce qui manque c'est dire alors oui
dans lawrence
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait comme vous
l'avez ap non ça c'est pas les payer
[Rires]
journaliste au monde qui s'appelle ici
c'est ma vie rêvée des séries pardon et
lawrence d'arabie
sortez un peu pas mal au tournoi malte
lawrence d'arabie ça vous apprenez
sauval la lessive ou paix alors là les
vannes plus de 85 on les fera tout à
l'heure on va regarder quand même le
clash avec matteo ça va il m'a fait
coucou médaille je croyais pas bellens
aurait pu votre style votre style doc
gynéco mais je trouve absolument
charmant et il est absolument exquis
avec la gente féminine
je suis extrêmement bien il est très
cucul non mais c'est vrai il est très
cultivé la lutte adéquates a vraiment lu
le dernier houellebecq toi non gelée
survolé à dépasser des libyens n'est pas
c'est comme un tueur